hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain a Russian horror Supernatural
film called row 19. spoilers ahead watch
out and take care
[Music]
the movie starts inside an airplane
which is heading to Nova sabersk Russia
I know I butchered that among the few
passengers on board or seven-year-old
Katya and her mom it is the little
girl's first time but she seems quite
calm about the whole experience however
after she falls asleep disaster strikes
one of the plane's engines starts
malfunctioning because of which violent
turbulence ensues when Katya wakes up
she doesn't find her mom around and
starts panicking but what she does spot
is a strange old lady who is chanting
some gibberish behind her the next
second the pilots lose total control of
the plane and eventually it crashes
everyone on board passes away except for
little Katya who has miraculously
survived following this the scene cuts
to 20 years after the incident Katya has
long recovered from the trauma and has a
daughter named Diana as far as work is
concerned she is one of the most
successful psychiatrists in town one day
some reporters Corner Katya in a park
and start asking her unnecessary
questions about that Unfaithful day they
want to know how she managed to survive
the unthinkable however Katya simply
brushes them off and leaves claiming
that she has an important meeting to
attend the next night the
mother-daughter Duo boards a plane to
Moscow to catch up with the relatives it
is revealed that after the incident
Katya is no longer afraid of flights so
she boards this one despite the weather
being terribly bad there are only a few
passengers on board for that reason
meanwhile Katja gets acquainted with a
handsome young man named Alexi he helps
her with the luggage and then gets
seated right across from them as the
plane prepares to take off Katya starts
opening up with the stranger but just
then she hears a commotion in the back
turns out that an old woman is having
second thoughts about traveling in this
weather so she is requesting the flight
attendant to Let Her Go however her
husband is adamant to stop her Katya
being a psychologist immediately Springs
into action and calms the old woman down
she then gives her some stress relief
pills before heading back to her seat
I'm a professional pick these drugs
elsewhere in the front rows we are
introduced to the two remaining
passengers one of them is a rich
businessman named Nikolai while the
other one is a sketch artist named Pavel
who looks more like a junkie Nikolai
arrogantly tries to initiate a
conversation but the artist doesn't pay
much attention to him meanwhile Katya
starts hearing some strange noises so
she rushes to the bathroom and takes
some pills turns out that she is
suffering from OCD which makes her
overthink things after a while she
proceeds to head back to her seat but
when she opens the door something
shocking happens Katya strangely finds
herself in her childhood home where she
used to live with her mother before the
crash took place Katya mixed up the OCD
and LSD pills again she wanders around
in bewilderment until she finds a door
which leads her back to the plane later
Alexei notices that she is feeling very
uncomfortable and asks if she is all
right Katya doesn't say a word so little
Diana reveals everything about how her
mom was the sole survivor of a deadly
plane crash 20 years ago at present she
acts as if she is not scared of flights
but deep down she is still troubled
hearing this Alexei is taken aback in
the next scene the plane finally takes
off and Katya someone calms down she
then starts a conversation with Alexei
where the latter reveals that he is a
war correspondent he has traveled to
literally all of the combat zones in the
world in return Katya also talks about
her work as a psychiatrist a few hours
later everyone falls asleep and Katya
has a dream where she sees her younger
self she and her mom are having a normal
conversation about their day just then
Katya notices that her mother's face is
wounded and burnt she inquires if they
died in the plane crash but the mom
reassures her that it's just a nightmare
and that they are fine following this
the mom suddenly becomes possessed
prompting Katya to wake up in the plane
unfortunately the situation isn't any
better here the plane is going through a
rough turbulence period because of which
the old man in the back row suffers a
cardiac arrest Katya and the flight
attendants rushed to help and
immediately start performing CPR after a
few seconds the man suddenly wakes up
with a possess luck grabs Katya Whispers
something in her ear and then passes out
again the turbulence also keeps getting
worse and when Katya glances around she
notices a strange black hand lurking
behind a seat suddenly the old man
breathes his last and passes away
leaving his wife devastated the
passengers don't even get time to
console her as the deadly turbulence
forces them back to their seats Katya
slowly loses Consciousness because of
the lack of oxygen in her body when she
wakes up though the turbulence is gone
and everything is reverted back to
normalcy that old dude's still dead
though Katya immediately approaches
Alexei and tells him that the old men
whispered the same words into her ears
that a strange old lady had 20 years ago
on the doomed flight to novosibirsk it
is almost as if the woman has cursed her
to die and that's why all of this is
happening however Alexa doesn't believe
any of that he simply tells her that
she's hallucinating because of the pills
she took earlier after a while the
flight attendants take the deceased old
man to the front of the plane and cover
him up however this may Kachi even more
suspicious as despite everything that
has happened the captain still hasn't
made any announcements to make matters
more weird the Deep scars in her leg
that she sustained 20 years ago have
also vanished okay that yeah that
actually is weird meanwhile little Diana
draws a picture of the plane where she
and her mom are sitting in the back seat
she then requests to change the seats
but Katya refuses all this while the
latter keeps saying the same weird black
figures around the plane as the weather
keeps deteriorating the flight attendant
makes an announcement she reveals that
the plane will make an emergency landing
in no Visa beersk the same city where
Kachi was headed 20 years ago meanwhile
a strange liquid starts dripping onto
the rich businessman nikolai's shoes
irritating him he tries to calm himself
down by smoking but as soon as he lights
a fire the strange liquid ignites
completely covering him in Flames Katya
and the rest of the passengers
immediately come to his Aid however by
the time they extinguish the fire
Nikolai has suffered extreme third
degree burns smoking is bad for your
health while the flight attendants
rushed to bring him first aid Katya
heads towards her daughter but just like
before she only notices the same creepy
figures lurking behind the seats then
suddenly Katya has another Vision where
she is taken to 24 hours earlier she and
her daughter are discussing if they
should board the flight to Moscow little
Diana says she doesn't want to but Katya
somehow convinces her at this point the
scar is clearly visible on her leg that
night as Katya is wandering around the
house she suddenly hears her daughter
screams terrified she rushes to her
bedroom but finds it locked Katya tries
her best to open the door and this is
when she snaps out of her vision soon a
worried Diana comes running to her and
reveals that Katya walked right past her
this surprises the latter and she
apologizes to the little girl for her
carelessness their emotional moment is
cut short however when Alexei arrives
and asks for kachi's help in Saving
Nikolai shortly after they start
treating the poor man his Airways are
blocked so Katya carefully places his
head in an upright position giving him a
tiny any bit of respite then as she is
clearing her hand she reveals to Alexei
that her hallucinations have become so
severe that she has started to confuse
imagination with reality meanwhile Pavel
keeps on sketching something while
mumbling some unintelligible words
seeing him so carefree and nonchalant in
such a situation Katya loses it and
starts berating him however she soon
stops when Alexei makes her realize that
her daughter is watching all of a sudden
the burnt man tries to reach for his
phone while uttering some words so Pavel
quickly takes his phone out and displays
his family picture seeing this Nikolai
breathes a sigh of relief before
succumbing to his injuries now that two
people on board the plane have died
Katya approaches Pavel and apologizes to
him for her earlier actions in response
the artist says that he sometimes gets
lost while drawing as the two continue
conversing Katya suddenly realizes that
the old woman has been in the washroom
for an unusually long time she rushes to
inspect but the flight attendants tell
her to go back to her seat however Katya
isn't going to be pushed around round
anymore and when she starts arguing the
attendants reluctantly opened the door
only to learn that the washroom is empty
that lady flushed herself down the
toilet stunned Katya prepares to go back
to the seat but right then the old man
who is supposed to be dead suddenly
pushes her then a bunch of dark hands
hold her down seemingly to kill her but
Katya soon snaps out of her visions and
heads straight to her daughter realizing
that something bad is about to happen
she tells Diana that they should leave
the plane immediately despite them being
mid-flight Alexa tries to stop them but
suddenly he starts bleeding from his
eyes and passes out following this the
two flight attendants also try to
persuade Katya from leaving they explain
that it is only a matter of minutes
before they land in noveisberg and that
waiting is the safest option just then
one of the flight attendants starts
vomiting water resulting in her horrible
death a terrified Katya then approaches
Pavel and snatches his Sketchbook when
she goes through it she realizes that he
has been drawing her Visions about the
dark figures all along when she notices
an exit door in one of his sketches
Pavel Burns and dissipates Into Thin Air
Katya then heads towards the Exeter with
Diana but at the same time the remaining
flight attendant and Alexa try to stop
her they mentioned that something very
bad awaits her on the other side of the
door right then an invisible force pulls
the flight attendant and smashes her
against the floor while Alexei starts
bleeding from his head and passes away
seeing this Katya strikes the door with
all her might and eventually opens it
however what she sees on the other side
shocks her to the core it is another
plane cabin that looks exactly like the
one she came from despite this Katya
doesn't lose hope and continues going
through the exit doors until she comes
across a completely new cabin however at
this point Diana isn't with her but at
the end of the hall there is also a
strange dark figure with her alarmed
Katya rushes to save her daughter but
everything goes into slow motion this is
when everything finally starts to
unravel in a shocking turn of events it
is revealed that the entire scenario
inside the plane isn't real Katya is
still on the doomed plane which is soon
going to crash and end up in Flames the
old woman whom Katya had always thought
of as a bad person is actually chanting
a prayer to put Katya to sleep she
doesn't want the little girl to witness
the horrors that are about to befall her
because of this time moves slowly for
Katya and she starts imagining a future
where she is still alive she has
everything a good job a loving daughter
and most importantly no [__] husband
I mean a safe environment to live in
however as the plane rapidly plunges to
the ground Katya tries to wake up as she
doesn't want to die so The Old Woman
releases Katya from her spell and now
her fate lies in her own hands following
this Katya returns to her daughter to
bid one final goodbye after they hug
Diana tells her mom to carefully
remember her surroundings implying that
there may still be a way to escape just
then Katja recalls the picture which her
daughter had drawn earlier it showed
that they were in the last row I.E Ronan
in the next scene we are taken back to
the doomed plane from 20 years ago
surprisingly the same people that Katya
has been interacting with in the future
are seen on this plane all of a sudden
the old man suffers from a cardiac
arrest sokacha's mom rushes to check up
on him a few minutes later as the plane
is on its way to crash little Kachi
wakes up and heads straight towards row
19 on her way she catches up with her
mom and also Alexei the latter helps
them get seated in row 19 but before he
can join them an explosion takes his
life good thing seat belts protect
against explosions soon the plane
crashes into a lake disintegrating it
into several pieces it appears as if no
survivors are left behind but
miraculously both Katya and her mom are
alive because of the little girl's quick
thinking they are left unharmed as row
19 is the only part of the plane that
did not get destroyed the movie ends as
they Cry tears of joy grateful that they
have been given a second chance at life
katya's daughter doesn't exist anymore
though that's kind of depressing
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching